là đù người nâng sự bởi người của mình.
Tổng thủng, phởi nào, vô lúc đi, Maze en eskiing em của một tháng 2 tháng báo,
vong đầm phản thứ 2, dựu quay nè, ngà và mi.
Nhằm tim kếm giải pháp, chấm giất xung đồ, sẽ giản giá tại Agu đà B,
cắt tiếp của quốc, arah thống nhất trong ngoài một bốn để mung năm tăng 2,
thay diện em của một tháng 2, như cái hoạt bắt đầu.
Trong thông điệp đăng trên mạng xa hội Hệch,
không sẽ nè xíu cho biết kế, sẵn sàng tham gia các cuộc thảo luật thức trất và tý vong,
tý trình đàn phản sẽ đưa các bên đến gần hơn một giải pháp lồ dài.
Nen đặc u cuối nâh không nhiều lý dò, điều trình, lý trình.
Thông báo đúng đưa ra sau khi một đặc phay viên tất cao của tổng thống nha bệnh của tiền,
có cuu gặp với giới chức Mỹ tại bão Florida,
mạc không có sự tham dựu của đại dịch u cuối nâh.
Hien, các diện bãi lình và nhà trang vẫn chưa xan nhận chính thức li khọt mới.
Chúc đó ở ba phải đoàn đã gặp nhau trong cuộc gặp đầu tiên tại Abu Dhabi,
ngay hôm nay ba và ngay hôm trước thăm một mạc không đặt được kết quả của thế.
Cũng trong ngày 1.2 trong video phát biểu hàng ngày,
Oph Zenski nhìn mạnh thăm đến lạnh thổ chỉ của thế được giải quyết,
nếu có tiếp sức trực tiếp ở tất miếng thủ,
đông thời thử nhận trên trình đàn phản đang ở giải đoạn có khăn và kết quả và trở giang.